donc nous accueillons et je vous
remercie madame la ministre Madame Agnès
firmain lebaudeau vous êtes chargé
auprès du ministre de la Santé de
l'organisation territoriale et des
professions de santé pour être tout à
fait clair nous avons sollicité votre
Ministre de tutelle monsieur Aurélien
Rousseau qui dans sa réponse nous a
recommandé de de de de vous
auditionnerette compé dans voilà cette
compéten est dans votre feuille de route
je tiens à vous dire madame la ministre
que c'est une commission d'enquête qui a
pour objet comprendre
euh on on n'est vraiment pas là pour euh
euh pointer des responsabilités trouver
des bous émissaires euh une politique
publique est quelque chose qui est
complexe celle-ci est peut-être
particulièrement euh elle se heurte à
beaucoup de freins que nous avons
cherché à identifier elle est
interministérielle en soi euh et donc
nous euh nous auditionnons les ministre
dans cette dans cette fin de de de
parcours de travaux pour comprendre euh
quel regard vous portez sur votre propre
administration sur cette politique
publique quel est l'ordre de priorité
comment est-ce qu'elle rentre dans votre
agenda euh quel regard vous portez sur
ce qu'elle a d'interministériel comment
est-ce que ça se passe de ce point de
vue-là au niveau de vos services au
niveau de votre cabinet au niveau de et
puis euh à votre propre niveau sachant
que euh la dimension santé est euh un un
point focal particulier euh le les
travaux de linerm qu'ils ont actualisé
récemment la fameuse
collective a été le déclencheur d'une
prise de conscience d'un enjeu de santé
sur les produits phytopharmaceutiques
c'est au centre de la préoccupation de
nombreuses de nombreux collectifs
citoyens organisations ONG association
que nous que nous avons auditionné
euh et c'est une politique publique qui
doit rentrer dans une équation complexe
avec beaucoup de paramètres la
biodiversité l'eau la souveraineté
alimentaire le revenu
agricole on peut donc considérer qu'il y
a a une hiérarchie ou un agencement de
ces différents paramètres qui qui est
complexe à définir et à matérialiser en
interministériel c'est cette complexité
que nous allons essayer d'aborder avec
vous avec vous
aujourd'hui je vais donc vous laisser la
parole pour un propos liminire d'une
dizaine de minutes si vous voulez bien
limiter à ce temps-l pour laisser le
temps au rapporteurs et au membres de la
commission ensuite d'avoir un échange
avec avec
vous et je vous rappelle que cette
audition est ouverte à la presse qu'elle
est retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée et que vous êtes tenu de
prêter serment de dire la vérité toute
la vérité rien que la vérité en vertu de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonction au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires et je vais donc vous
demander de lever la main droite et de
dire je le jure je vous remercie madame
la ministre et je vous laisse la
parole monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur madamees monsieurs les
députés tout d'abord merci monsieur le
Président de vos propos liminires et sur
l'explication et le sens que vous avez
souhaité donner à votre commission
d'enquête c'est-à-dire comprendre
comprendre la complexité eu de de ce
dossier euh je tiens à le dire sans
higuité la réduction de l'utilisation et
donc de l'exposition aux produits
phytosanitaires concernent tous les
ministères en premier chef de ceux en
charge de l'agriculture de
l'environnement mais aussi de la santé
en effet l'usage des pesticides est
devenu une question sociétale ne
concernant plus seulement les
agriculteurs c'est désormais une attente
citoyenne forte parfaitement légitime
puisque ces dernières années les études
visant à mieux apprécier l'exposition de
la population et les effets des produits
phytopharmaceutiques sur la santé
humaine se sont multipliés et ont mis en
évidence des impacts sanitaires
l'approche interministérielle constitue
donc une nécessité pour préserver la
santé humaine et la santé des milieux
dans lesquels nous
vivons cette approche nous la mettons en
place au quotidien depuis 2009 au
travers des différents plans et
stratégies écopyo qui se sont succédés
la première ministre a renouvelé la
volonté lors du dernier Salon
International de l'Agriculture de
réduire de 50 % notre utilisation des
produits phytosanitaires je tiens
d'ailleurs à préciser de nouveau qu'il
ne s'agit pas là d'une initiative
française isolée mais bien d'une
ambition européenne sur laquelle notre
pays n'est d'ailleurs pas en retard
malgré beaucoup de controverses cette
ambition au ministère de la santé et de
la prévention nous devons y contribuer
avec pragmatisme et transparence
pragmatisme car nous devons avoir
conscience des limites de l'interdiction
de l'usage des pesticides mettant en jeu
notre souveraineté alimentaire
transparence car nous devons tout mettre
en œuvre pour mieux comprendre et
prévenir les impacts sanitaires et
environnementaux qui sont devenus une
source de préoccupation légitime pour
nos concitoyens cela passe par le
renforcement des connaissances depuis
quelques années nous détectons de plus
en plus et dans tous les milieux des
pesticides ou des produits issus de leur
dégradation à savoir les métabolites
cependant et c'est important de le
souligner tout ce que l'on détecte ne
présente pas forcément un risque
sanitaire dans tous les cas et comme
pour tous les risques il nous faut
distinguer ce qui relève des
connaissances actuelles des
connaissances non disponibles ou encore
des expertises à mobiliser pour combler
ces écarts si toutes les les attentes
des citoyens évoluent vite les études
également de nombrebreuses études
épidémiologiques pointent désormais du
doigt le risque d'une exposition
domestique et professionnelle sur la
santé des travailleurs agricoles des
riverins ou encore de certains publics
vulnérables tels que les femmes
enceintes ou les enfants le CIE cancer
de la prostate maladie Parkinson sont
autant de pathologies qui qui sen sont
des conséquences alors même que les
liens entre exposition aux pesticides et
pathologies restent complexe à établir
nous savons d'ors et déjà que s'agissant
des professionnels agricoles la maladie
de Parkinson et certaines hémopathies
Malines sont aujourd'hui reconnues comme
maladie professionnell provoquées par
les produit produit
phytopharmaceutiqu cela veut dire que
dans ce cadre il nous faut tout faire
pour protéger les travailleurs et les
indemniser le cas échéant c'est le cas
notamment grâce aux mesures de
protections individuelles mises en œuvre
par les
agricultures je tiens d'ailleurs à
rappeler l'engagement des agriculteurs
et des travailleurs agricoles qui ont
pleinement conscience de ces enjeux et
de la nécessité de protéger leur santé
mais également la santé de leur de leurs
concitoyens c'est aussi le cas avec le
fond d'indemnisation des victimes de
pesticid le fivp créé par la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2020 ce fond qui monte en charge
doublement des demande en 2022 a permis
une réelle avancée de l'indemnisation
des victimes professionnelles des
pesticides notamment les victimes de la
chore d'écon aux Antilles avec
l'intégration en 2022 dans les tableaux
de maladies professionnelles du cancer
de la prostate provoqué par les
pesticides dont le chlord d'con
concernant la population générale et
notamment les riverins de parcelles
agricoles des pré occupation existe
également quant au risque d'atteinte du
neurodéveloppement d'impact sur la
granesse de développement des cancers de
l'adulte de cancer pédiatrique ainsi que
de la maladie de Parkinson cependant
pour ces maladies la caractérisation du
lien est aujourd'hui plus faible en
dehors de l'exposition inutéro cela veut
donc dire qu'il faut bien différencier
la perception du risque le risque avéré
et les mesures de protection à mettre en
place c'est notamment pour améliorer nos
connaissances que nous avons fait le
choix de financer pestive en mobilisant
la redevance pour pollution diffuse
assise sur les ventes de produits
phytosanitaires au nom du principe polur
payeur l'étude pestirive mené par santé
publique France et lanè financé en
grande partie par le plan ecopyo 2 est
la première étude de grande ampleur
visant à mieux connaître et comprendre
l'exposition au produits
phyopharmaceutiques des personnes
vivants près des cultures viticoles les
premiers résultats de cette étude sont
attendus pour le début de l'année
2025 la montée en charge de la
connaissance doit s'accompagner de
mesures claires permettant de renforcer
la protection de l'ensemble des
populations cela passe par
l'interdiction des cmr1 cancérigène
mutagène
reprotoxique comme vous l'avez rappelé
lors de cette commission d'enquête les
substances classées cmr1 sont depuis
2014 retirées du marché cette mesure est
très importante d'abord parce qu'elle
démontre notre volonté de protéger
ensuite parce qu'elle affiche notre
intransigence lorsqu'un danger est
spfiquement et scientifiquement prouvé
donc par exemple
l'époxyconazol ou le propiconazol ou
encore le fluurochlordicone classé cmr1
dès
2017 nous pouvons nous féliciter
également des avancées portées d'une
part par le cadre réglementaire relatif
aux zones de nontaitement dit ZNT qui a
connu plusieurs évolutions récentes et
d'autre part par la loi Lab de 2014 dont
le périmètre d'interdiction en matière
d'utilisation des produits
phytopharmaceutique s'est vu élargi à
plusieurs reprises ainsi avec la loi Lab
depuis le 1er janvier 2002 l'utilisation
des produits phytopharmaceutiques est
interdit dans tous les lieux de vie mais
le renforcement de la protection de la
population doit également passer par une
meilleure anticipation liée à l'exposome
et une meilleure maîtrise des milieux
sur cela l'un d'entre eux retient toute
mon intention tant sa nécessité nous est
vitale l'eau l'eau représente un enjeu
de santé majeur à plus d'un titre
préserver une ressource de plus en plus
précieuse tout en garantissant sa
qualité est un des objectifs
prioritaires du ministère de la santé et
de la prévention à cet égard je rappelle
le travail conduit par les agences
régionales de santé qui uvrent au
quotidien dans le cadre du contrôle
sanitaire de l'eau destinée à la
consommation humaine au cours de ces
derniers mois vous le savez la mise à
jour régulière des molécules suivies
dans les eaux destinées à la
consommation humaine a fait apparaître
la présence de certains produits
phytopharmaceutiques et leur métabolites
dans les ressources en eau et dans les
eaux distribuées au robinets des
consommateurs je pense en particulier au
métabolite du chlorotalony du
sméthalochlore ou de la
chlorideazone mobilisant les autorités
nationales et locales la question de la
qualité des eaux destinées à la
consommation humaine doit trouver une
place centrale dans nos débats aussi je
souhaite que nous portions en
interministériel une politique
ambitieuse et que les mesures de
réduction des intrans et de protection
sur les captages utilisés pour la prod
de l'eau que nous consommons au
quotidien soit renforcé comme le plan
eau présenté en mars dernier nous y
engage mon ministère est également
attentif au sujet de la protection des
captages d'eau portable en tant que zone
sensible d'eau potable en tant que zone
sensible dans le cadre du règlement
européen usage durable des PES des
pesticides dit sûr en cours de
renégociation renforcer la protection et
réduire l'exposition c'est aussi
permettre au riverins personnes exposées
de signaler plus fac facilement un effet
indésirable pour cela nous continuerons
le déploiement national d'un dispositif
de signalement des expositions aux
produits
phytoparmaceutiques nous pourrons
répondre ainsi aux attentes de nombreux
concitoyens en articulation avec le
dispositif des chartes d'engagement
d'utilisation des produits Phyt
phytosanitaire pour les agriculteurs
déjà engagés au niveau
territorial force est de constater que
notre engagement sur le sujet est bien
réel et pourtant je partage avec vous
des résultats qui ne sont toujours pas à
la hauteur de l'enjeu mais alors quelles
seraient les autres solutions est-ce
àdire qu'il faudrait par principe de
précaution tout interdire tout de suite
alors même que toutes les connaissances
ne sont pas disponibles ou que les
expositions po loin sont multiples via
l'eau via l'alimentation via l'air je ne
suis pas certaine que tout passe par
l'interdiction également je ne suis pas
certaine que le principe de précaution
corresponde obligatoirement à
l'interdiction en tant que pharmacienne
si je peux me permettre une analogie et
je crois que je ne suis pas la seule à
la faire les produits de santé sont
également potentiellement dangereux pour
la santé et c'est bien parce qu'on les
utilise selon un dosage précis et selon
des recommandations scientifiquement
fondés qu'ils répondent à nos besoins
ainsi si la boussole de notre action est
bien la réduction de l'utilisation des
produits phytosanitaires et de
l'exposition de la population générale
et des agriculteurs premiè exposés il
nous faudra continuer à accompagner les
agriculteurs sur leurs usages de plus si
jeue mon analogie il nous faudra
renforcer à l'image de la farm
ovigilance pour les médicaments la phyto
pharmacovigilance pour les pesticides si
nous voulons mieux connaître les risques
liés à l'exposition mais aussi au cumul
des expositions les effets cocktail ou
effet dose être en mesure de savoir quel
produit a été utilisé dans quelle
quantité et à quel endroit est
fondamental aujourd'hui cela est
réglementairement prévu mais avec la
nouvelle stratégie écofyo 2030 nous
viendrons améliorer ces recueils
d'informations notamment en numérisant
le processus la clé sera et je le répète
dans la transparence et dans
l'information de chacun et de chacune
sur les risques dans ce sens la place
des professionnels de santé pour accom
pour accompagner nos concitoyens est un
levier dans la stratégie écofito 2030
nous renforcerons la place des
professionnels de santé pour que les
médecins puissent mieux informer nos
concitoyens mesdames messieurs votre
commission d'enquête montre que le sujet
est d'une importance majeure c'est parce
qu'il est important qu'il faut savoir
accept sa complexité il n'y a pas une
réponse unique et je pense que vous
l'avez constaté chacun en fonction de
son point de vue et de sa place vous les
apportera les miennes seront celles du
ministère délégué dont j'ai la charge et
comme je suis dans le cadre du
commission d'enquête je je me limiterai
dans mes réponses aux sujets qui sont
directement sous ma responsabilité je
suis désormais prête à répondre à vos
questions merci Mad le ministre monsieur
le
rapporteur
oui merci madame la ministre pour vos
propos liminminires je CIS qu'on
interprète pas mal les propos du
président en introductionin quand il
disait on cherche à comprendre on
cherche à comprendre où sont les
responsabilités c'est c'est clair c'est
par contre on ne cherche pas a priori
des coupables et voilà mais on cherche
on ira jusqu'au bout de des explications
et des responsabilités dans ces
responsabilités je vous le dis
d'emblé pour avoir
conduit une mission du gouvernement en 2
14 c'est c'est une des bornes qu'on a
fixé pour les 10 ans d'évaluation pour
avoir en permanence suivi ces sujets et
au bout de je ne sais pas combien
d'heures d'audition le ministère de la
Santé je vous le dis sans j'ai aucune
accusation personnelle vous le
comprendrez bien apparaissait comme le
grand absent des débats et des des
donneurs d'ordre sur sur le sujeton il
nous semble et c'est notre conviction
qui nous animit dès le départ c'est
qu'il devrait être au centre de des
préoccupations ça semble être votre
volonté don acte donc je vais maintenant
éprouver cette volonté à travers
quelques questions question qui vont
venir préciser ce que vous faites la
première question elle est elle est
de elle est sur la démocratie il y a un
plan il y a une commission parlementaire
qui le président l'a dit et je crois que
vous pouvez nous faire tous confiance
vise à être utile au débat public c'est
une
contribution à l'amélioration des
politiques publiques on a été on a écrit
à Matignon pour leur dire que c'it bien
de sortir un écho phito 2030 mais son a
été bien d'attendre sûr d'une part le
règlement européen qui aboutissent et
d'autre part les résultats de la
commission d'enquête parlementaire et je
voudrais vous demander à vous
personnellement la réponse a été plutôt
encourageante de la part du gouvernement
en disant queon attendrait début 2024
pour pour écrire le plan dans sa forme
diverse madame les ministre serez-vous
attentive à nos
recommandations par respect pour le
Parlement que par ailleurs vous
chérissez la réponse la première
question n'est pas
difficile vous avez fait la fois la
question et la réponse non non euh tout
d'abord je vais dans mes propos
liminires j'ai remercié le président
c'est justement parce que c'est l'état
d'esprit qui qui qui qui a prèsvalu dans
les propos du président que je me suis
permis de de de dire que j'étais
j'allais dire attentive au propos quand
je dis comprendre c'est surtout pas pour
accuser c'est comprendre la
complexité du sujet et c'est ce en quoi
j'ai remercié le président
euh le grand absent la santé je vais
être très clair et ce pourquoi je suis
là aujourd'hui euh devant de vous c'est
parce que pour la première fois pour la
première fois au ministère de la Santé
un ministre a dans sa feuille de route
clairement écrit les enjeux autour de la
santé environnementale les enjeux autour
de la santé environnementale c'est
clairement écrit dans ma feuille de
route c'est pour ça que c'est moi qui
est là aujourd'hui et que le ministre de
la santé et de la prévention a souhaité
que je sois présente ici aujourd'hui
c'est parce que c'est clairement écrit
dans ma feuille de route et c'est
tellement écrit dans ma feuille de route
et que nous souhaitons tellement
travailler en
interministériel que toutes les réunions
qui ont ont lieu sur tous les sujets qui
concernent la santé environnementale
systématiquement si vous regardez bien
et je sais que vous êtes attentif à ces
sujets là il y a toujours au côté du
ministère de la transition écologique au
côté du ministère de l'Agriculture à la
fois la la représentation du ministère
de la Santé à travers moi à travers la
recherche la la ministre en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche nous faisons toutes ces
réunions systématiquement à tris ou
quatre mais systématiquement nous sommes
toujours présents lorsqu'on parle de
l'air lorsqu'on parle de ZFE il y a à la
fois le ministre de MTCT du ministre des
Transports et la santé donc c'est pour
répondre à l'enjeu autour de
l'interministérialité et à la volonté de
mettre la santé la santé comme un enjeu
primordial sur ces sur cette
problématique et sur votre première
question véritablement sur l'enjeu de la
démocratie et sur le fait
que nous serons très attentifs j'allais
dire au rapport issu de votre commission
d'enquête la réponse c'est bien
évidemment oui vous l'avez rappelé la la
parlementaire que j'étais il y a encore
quelques mois souhaite que nous soyons
toujours très attentifs aux travaux
faites par les parlementaires c'est un
enjeu important c'est un enjeu important
pour la démocratie mais c'est aussi un
enjeu important parce que vous avez fait
un travail et un travail
important et qui nous importe de pouvoir
j'allais dire le consulter et donc dans
la stratégie écito
elle avance mais bien sûr nous
regarderons avec attention la conclusion
de vos travaux
merci madame la ministre je j'entends
ben je vous remercie pour cette
disposition d'esprit et mais je note
qu'à travers l'affirmation de
l'originalité de votre mission et de sa
nouveauté on peut faire ensemble le
constat que ça a été peut-être un
élément manquant par le passé en tout
cas qui avit besoin de le réaffirmer à
travers votre compétence et votre
engagement dont on ne doute pas à cet
instant mais ça ça peut exister
auparavant et ça confirmerait plutôt
l'hypothèse que je posais initialement
c'est derrière nous essayer de regarder
quelques points plus précis euh vous
vous lancez depuis pestiive moi j'ai un
souvenir si on prend 10 ans euh c'est à
peu près vers 201526 j'ai un doute que
les questions de Riverin surgissent à
travers l'affaire d'une école et cetera
donc il y a l'opinion publique est ému
c'est pas nouveau hein mais ému et je me
souviens pour avoir rendu le rapport un
an ou deux avant de de m'en être voulu
de pas avoir vu ce sujet émerger quoi
donc c'est un rapport qui ne parle pas
du tout des riverins donc c'est un sujet
qui émerge alors c'est nouveau et en
même temps ça a quand même 8 9 ans et on
peut s'étonner tout de même que euh
l'étude soit seulement lancée qu'il
faille attendre encore un an pour avoir
ses résultats sur un sujet qui est
absolument crucial quoi c'est c'est
j'habite à un endroit et la distance du
pullvet la nature des des produits
utilisés leurs conditions d'utilisation
et cetera on disposait pas d'études
scientifiques documentées auparavant
donc ça fait maintenant euh 8 ans à peu
près qu'on a qu'on a tardé qu'on aurait
tardé à à documenter ce ce risque là du
point de vue sanitaire vous pouvez nous
expliquer je vais compléter euh la ma
réponse à votre première question
puisque vous avez rebondi je vais me
permettre de rebondir sur
euh tout d'abord vous dire que euh la
crise sanitaire est aussi passée par là
sur la prise de conscience générale que
de travailler sur ces sujets
euh il faut savoir aussi j'allais dire
apprendre de de ces crises sanitaires et
je pense que
placer replacer les enjeux de la santé
autour du concept one else on peut aussi
l'affirmer et c'est une volonté
d'affirmation c'est pas seulement une
volonté d'affirmation mais de dire que
la santé environnementale est un enjeu
majeur et devient un enjeu de santé
publique peut-être on peut
aussi dire que c'est une un des rétexes
importants de la crise de la crise de la
crise covid ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'avant ce qui ne veut pas dire
qu'avant ça n'était pas prise en compte
mais en tout cas ça nétait pas affiché
là c'est clairement affiché et que la
volonté de de travailler sur une seule
santé le oneels et est clairement dans
la feuille de route qui qui est la
mienne après pour répondre à la question
sur le P pestirive et les les les
résultats qui seront attendus 2025 c'est
pas parce queon parle et jeeni parlé
dans mes propos introductif que de
peséif qu'avant il n'y avait rien
euh on a également été mobilisé autour
de différentes études je vais vous en
citer trois euh gocap à gris dont
l'objectif était de d'étudier le risque
d'apparition de concherche enfant au
regard de la proximité de certaines
familles de culture les premiers
résultats ont d'ailleurs été publiés en
octobre dernier euh l'étude d''estban
qui était lancé par santé publique
France et qui va se prolonger euh avec
l'étude Albane euh et puis l'expertise
l'expertise collective de l'inserbe
pesticides et effets sur la santé et
nouvelles données donc je dis que tout
ça c'était bien en amont et c'est bien
complété l'étude pestirive que j'ai
uniquement cité dans mon propos
liminire merci pour ces précisions parce
qu'on aurait on aurait on a on aurait
autrement dénoncer une lacune mais il y
a eu différentes initiatives celle de
l'inserme nous sert de de Born ça on a
pris de ça aurait été écocentré que de
prendre le rapport 2014 donc on a pris
2013 premier rapport de l'incern
complété en 2021 c'est bien ça hein
c'est deuxème parition qui vient
confirmer par les Cortes étudier les
intuitions posées en 2013 et c'est bien
2013- 2023 voilà c'est merci pour pour
pour C pour ces précisions je vais tout
de suite rebondir
sur sur vos sur la question de de d' un
sujet qui nous tient à cœur parce que
c'est c'est j'étais à l'initiative dans
une PPL qui n'a pas qui n'a pas pu être
traité mais agès Buzin votre
prédécesseur avait tenu son engagement
on n pas pu l'examiner dans la niche
soci socialiste mais le coup près de de
minuit était tombé mais elle avait pris
juste le temps de prendre l'engagement
de le reprendre dans le PLFSS ce qui a
été fait l'automne suivant et et donc
cette fond phyoictime a été a été créé
on le vivait tous comme un compromis qui
avait été organisé avec le gouvernement
première étape en en écoutant ces
auteurs la MSA il y a peu de temps je
dois vous dire je peux être contredit
par les commissaires mais on partage
avec le président le sentiment que n
étions pas euh n pas eu l'impression
d'un dynamisme extraordinaire et que
quelques questions que nous posions
n'avait pas obtenu de réponse notamment
sur sur sur l'information des
agriculteurs qui paraissaient encore
lacunaire sur leur droit en la matière
sur la question desos l'exposition
inutéro une des fiertés de de de ce fond
phyovictime c'est qu'il
reconnaissait la la possible
contamination inutéo euh très peu très
peu de publicit et puis euh et puis
l'absence de prévention sur sur sur les
publicités qui concernent la
phytopharmacie dans dans la presse
spécialisé bref beaucoup de carences on
n' pas très bien compris comment toutes
ces informations qui remontaient
lentement mais sûrement vous avez dit ça
double on parle de sias hein mais c'est
c'est en train de doubler le registre
des maladies professionnelles est mieux
documenté donc tout tout ça se met on na
pas pas eu l'impression d'un très grand
un manque de volontarisme est-ce que
pour le ministère même siil la
délégation à la MSA même s'il y a un
fond qui est qui est géré qui est animé
par un président est-ce que pour le
ministère de la Santé est-ce que vous
veillez au dynamisme à la rapidité du
déploiement de ce fond qui est un effet
de justice mais avec beaucoup de retard
par rapport au passé he beaucoup de
retard est-ce que vous y vous vous vous
êtes déjà investi est-ce que vous avez
l'intention de vous investir dans la
dynamisation et et la pleine expression
du potentiel de ce fond tel que nous
l'avons avons en tout cas voulu au
Parlement
merci merci pour pour pour cette
question alors d'abord je vais pas beter
en touche parce que ce fond est géré par
le ministère du travail mais vous dire
quand même que sur ce fond il se trouve
que je reviens de martiniic et donc on a
beaucoup parlé de ce fond puisque j'ai
eu l'occasion
d'échanger avec des professionnels de
santé mais aussi avec Serge leimi qui
qui a beaucoup travailler et qui a
beaucoup œuvré pour ce fond
euh l'information nécessaire j'allais
dire pour pour les agriculteurs et tout
à l'heure dans mon propos liminire j'ai
parlé de la nire nécessaire aussi
information aux professionnels de santé
je pense que ça passera aussi par là ça
passera à mon sens d'abord par là on va
pas rajouter une couche aux
professionnels de santé mais je veux
dire queon voit bien lorsqu'un
professionnel de santé rencontre un
agiculteur qu'on puisse euh j'allais
dire en amont d'abord porter à
connaissance l'existence de ce fond je
crois que là aussi on doit multiplier
les les canaux dans information sur
l'existence de ce fond comme vous l'avez
rappelé qui est quand même assez récent
qui est quand même assez récent
euh mettre tous les tous les acteurs
j'allais dire à la
fois tous les voilà on peut aussi parler
des jeunes agriis on peut aussi parler
de la fessa en disant que ce fond existe
c'est aussi porté à connaissance même si
eux le même si eux le savent
euh bien sûr la reconnaissance là aussi
de l'exposition enuttero je l'ai dit je
l'ai aussi dit dans dans mon propos
liminaire en ce qui concerne la chore
d'con très clairement l'état a pris ses
respons ses responsabilités en parlant
d'un droit à réparation euh donc donc la
et d'ailleurs la montée en puissance de
l'utilisation de ce fond montre à quel
point euh sur je le redis une création
récente l'information commence à arriver
il faut continuer il faut continuer
euh il faut continuer à multiplier je le
redis les canaux euh
possible d'information pour porter à
connaissance l'existence même de ce fond
et d'ailleurs la reconnaissance et je
vais prendre l'exemple de de la
clordécone en décembre 2022 du cancer de
la prostate va aussi va aussi faire
monter en puissance l'utilisation même
de ce
fond pardon pour pour la contrainte
technique
oui c'est c'est justement sur ce cancer
de de de la prostate al j'ai fait une
petite enquête de de territoire il y a
par ailleurs des enquêtes
épidémiologiques qui sont déclenchés dès
lors qu'un un signal est fait mais quand
on a posé la question lors de l'audition
on a on a posé des questions simples en
disant elle est pas répertoriée comme
une des des des cibles en privilégié de
l'exposition au pesticides or c'est
celle qui remonte très fortement avec
qui en avez-vous parlé est-ce que ça
remonte à l'an quel est le dialogue avec
le ministère de la Santé et alors
peut-être une question de voilà mais on
aa on a besoin que à la fois ce qui
s'est passé dans Agrican et ce qui se
fait sur sur cet échantillon très
singulier des personnes qui souffrent de
de de qui souffrent d'une maladie dont
on on pressant qu'elle est lié au au à
l'exposition au phyo puiss que que tout
ça soit pleinement tiré dans l'esprit du
législateur encore une fois c'était on
répare et à partir de la réparation on
prévient hein c'est voilà et on n pas
senti cette dynamique c'est c'est c'est
vraiment c'est peut-être de notre faute
on l'a pas compris on n pas pris assez
de temps mais c'est c'est plus une
alerte c'est l'occasion et comprenez-le
ma ma remarque n'est pas du tout un
reproche et est plutôt de dire nous
avons appris cela nous allons l'écrire
et dès maintenant on vous alerte
vivement sur ce sujet on doit tirer
pleinement profit de cette innovation
dans dans le droit français je je vous
avez évoqué Wels
euh juste juste rapidement compléter
compléter ma réponse à cette C
réparation
euh d'ailleurs on l'a j'allais dire pour
l'instant et vous avez raison de dire
l'utiliser comme un droit à réparation
euh la reconnaissance euh comme maladie
du au cl desces par exemple sur concer
de la prostate date de décembre 2022
donc c'est c'est encore assez récent
donc dans la stratégie écyo 2030 et et
j'ai pas de doute que ça fasse partie
aussi peut-être de vos recommandations
il nous faut j'allais dire travailler à
la fois sur la prévention euh et et que
ça fasse clairement partie
intégrante le porter à connaissance de
ce fond et à la fois la prévention dans
la stratégie qui sera portée par ecito
2030 merci beaucoup vous avez évoqué
votre votre passion pour Wels est
partagé par le par le rapporteur qu j'ai
j'ai eu l'occasion d'écrire un article
pour la Fondation jean- là-dessus c'est
les origines on ne sait pas la crise du
covid-19 he ça a remis en évidence mais
la FA travaille avec l'OMS avec l'oie
sur ces sujets donc il y a des regards
croisés à l'échelle internationale c'est
une culture qui qui a été quand même une
des traces françaises hein il y a une
des contribution française forte
là-dessus on l'a intégré dans diverses
lois très concrètement pour le ministère
de la Santé effet cocktail
exposom mode de vie vous avez pointé
tous ces sujets quels sont les les
moyens dont vous vous dottez aujourd'hui
pour pour accentuer la recherche en la
matière et puis deuxème question connexe
avec le président et peut-être
l'ensemble des commissaires on avait été
parfois surpris de enfin c'est une
question générique c'est pas seulement
pour les phyo mais comment l'ensemble
des études scientifiques madame la
ministre s'articulle-ell les unes avec
les autres
linerme avec son son rapport affirmait
des choses qui n'était pas reprise dans
d'autres études il y a il y a une
problème de consolidation de l'ensemble
des études et des approches qui sont
faites et il nous semble que sur cette
question de encore une fois exposom
effet cocktail on a beaucoup d'études
mais on ne sait pas trop comment elles
sont hiérarchisées articuler on est dans
le on doute pas que vous y travaillez he
mais est-ce qu'il y a pas un travail de
grand architecte à faire la part du
ministère de la Santé pour que chacune
de ces études ouais je vous souffre
presque une réponse à vous à vous à vous
voir mais est-ce qu'il y a pas un manque
de ce point de vue là parce que les
controverses qui naissent des
différences
méthodologiques inévitaable mais qui ne
sont pas réarticulés hiérarchisés entre
ell et tout c'est du pain béni pour ceux
qui doutent et qui veulent faire douter
hein qui font semblant de douter et qui
veulent faire douter l'opinion publique
quoi et au nom d'intérêt particulier
donc vraiment la la force d'une science
hiérarchisée articulée nous paraît une
évidence et vous en êtes évidemment le
premier acteur
non alors déjà je je je vais réenir et
insister hein la santé environnementale
inscrite dans la feuille de route du
ministère de la Santé ça je crois que
c'est déjà une première pierre et une
première réponse sur toutes les les
études et et je l'ai redis à la fois
l'équilibre entre améliorer nos
connaissances qui sont absolument
nécessaires pour nous permettre de
démontrer scientifiquement la présence
ou l'absence de risque sur la santé ça
je crois que c'est quelque chose qu'il
nous faut continuer à faire euh et une
fois la démonstration faite cela nous
renforce dans la décision de
modification de suspension ou
d'interdiction d'usage ou de produits
phyto sanitair
en ce qui concerne la maîtrise des
risques des expositions et plus
généralement l'application de la méthode
une seule santé dit one else ou one else
dit une seule santé ça dépend dans quel
sens on le
dit mon ministère très clairement
défendra désormais la nécessité de
mettre en place une instance
interministérielle dédié à ces questions
de santé globale associant les
ministères de l'économie de la recherche
de l'agriculture et de l'environnement
c'est quelque chose que je porte c'est
quelque chose que je défend je pense que
c'est important si on veut emmener le
concept oneelse il faut vraiment qu'on
puisse aller aller en ce sens donc c'est
la deuxième pierre que j'aimerais
pouvoir euh voir j'allais dire
sat'atteler à la première qui est celui
du concept de santé environnementale qui
est porté dans ma feuille de
route merci Madame la Ministre euh je je
vais
c'est passionnant le dialogue avec vous
et je vous en remercie j'aurais encore
plein de questions je regardais que deux
parce qu'on est on est nombreux et je
veux que chacun des commissaires puisse
s'exprimer et vous interroger
euh la première concerne l'eau vous
semblez vous semblez entendre alors ça
pourrait être le ministre de l'écologie
qui le disent ou de l'alimentation parce
que c'est le premier aliment l'eau hein
c'est bon donc le ministère de
laagriculture mais c'est c'est c'est
incroyable ce qu'on a entendu des
agences de l'eau quoi quoi on va et des
agences de l'eau et de l'inrae et de
tous les experts on va vers une crise
grave de la ressource liée au stress
hydrique cumulé avec la permanence des
des des anciens produits et de leur
rémanence à travers les métabolites et
l'arrivée des et la maintenant enfin le
rythme et cetera enfin bref c'est c'est
c'est c'est il y a une alerte majeure or
nos
instruments sont des instruments mou
territorialisé objet de tractation
infini est-ce qu'on va avoir des
problèmes de ressources en eau parce
qu'on aura manqué d'autorité publique et
en matière d'autorité publique quelles
sont les décisions majeures qu'il
conviendrait de prendre sur les coptag
d'après vous pour assurer la sécurité
sanitaire de l'eau potable sans que ça
passe par des coûts prohibitifs en
matière de de traitement bien sûr
qu'elle reste accessible socialement à
tous et qu'elle puisse être portée par
les collectivités compétentes comment
résoudre cette équation avec avec une
forme de allez Jose le mot de l'xisme
aujourd'hui quand on a vu le nombre de
périmètres qui n'ont pas fait l'objet de
de de de mesures de protection le nombre
de captages sensibles sur lesquels on ne
mobilise pas les instruments existants
et avec la conscience sous-jacente
Madame le Ministre que les instruments
existants ne sont pas suffisants en la
matière donc quelle serait l'ambition de
du ministère de la Santé pour protéger
l'eau potable pour pour les Français
votre réponse est très
attendue préciser si et vous connaissez
ces sujets parce que vous avez été élu
territorial qu'on parle de périmètrre
rapprochés et de périmètre éloigné
merci alors c'est un sujet sur lequelle
il va être difficile de répondre en 2
minutes à la question je crois que c'est
presque un sujet qui
mériterait un débat un débat à lui seul
tant ce sujet est devenu un sujet
important tant en terme de quantité
d'eau en terme de ité et de dire que ce
sujet il est présenté là aussi en
interministériel puisque le plan haut
qui a été présenté en mars dernier en
mars dernier a été établi de façon inter
interministérielle et pour le coup très
interministérielle puisque dedans il a
ça allait aussi de
l'industrie en passant par la
biodiversité en passant bien sûr comme
chef de fila par le ministère de la
transition écologique mais aussi le
ministère de la Santé puisque la qualité
de l'eau relève de la compétence du
ministère de la Santé
donc vous le savez et je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure euh il y a l'enjeu autour de la
connaissance à la fois et de la
recherche des des produits et des
métabolites mais la connaissance de
l'impact sanitaire des métabolites de
pesticides dans les EAU destinées à la
consommation est partiel notamment car
les études produites lors de la demande
d'autorisation deis sur le marché ne
sont pas suffisantes pour le lever les
doutes sur les risques sanitaires et où
établir les fameuses Vmax et anticiper
la contamination de de ces eau de
consommation la nécessité de pouvoir
s'articuler et pour le coup on l'a bien
vu et je l'ai bien vu depuis maintenant
un an que j'ai en charge ce dossier
l'articulation entre les enjeux
territoriaux à travers les agences
régionales de santé et à travers le
ministère je peux vous assurer que les
allers-retours ils sont quasi journalier
sur ces sujets euh c'est un sujet dont
on parle et dont je parle très
régulièrement et que bien sûr le
ministère de la Santé le ministère
d'écologie sont auprès à la fois des
agences régionales qui ont la compétence
sur la qualité de l'eau et qui des facto
sur territorialement sont les relais
auprès des collectivités territoriales
sur tous ces sujetsl mais vous l'avez
dit ce sujet-là il est presque devant
nous
et on doit là aussi construire une
organisation notamment pour les élus
pour tenir là aussi un enjeu de
transparence envers les élus construire
un schéma organisationnel qui soit
lisible et visible et c'est ce à quoi
nous nous attelons notamment avec nos
relais dans les territoires que sont les
agences régionales de
santé on n pas le temps d'un
effectivement d'un grand débat ça mérite
mais dans le dialogue que nous avons eu
avec les différentes parties prenantes
il semble que les
ARS étai plutôt centré sur les
pollutions accidentelles que sur les
pollutions diffuses que leur mode
d'intervention qu' contrôle au robinet
le contrôle à la
distribution soit soit pas forcément au
niveau quand il s'agit des mesures de
prévention sur les périmètres donnés et
cetera bref que entre les agences et l'
RS et finalement ceux qui à la fin
peuvent mobiliser
des des plans d'intervention en matière
de de d'agroécologie voire des moyens de
maîtrise du foncier plus radicaux en
tout cas on appellera à ça dans dans
notre dans notre mission il y ait une
sorte de dissonance qui et est-ce que
est-ce que madame la ministre vous êtes
prête à envisager que agence de l'eau
ARS état territorial soit dans une forme
d'autorité publique qui se manifeste
plus clairement quand il s'agit de
protéger une ressource aussi vitale que
celle de l'eau
potable je suis euh alors vous allez
toujours sans doute trouver peut-être le
contre-exemple de ce que je dis mais je
suis intimement convaincu que c'est déjà
le cas euh sur des sujets sur lesquels
nous avons eu à travailler le lien euh
le lien entre euh
l'ARS les préfets les préfets et euh les
collectivités territorial euh se fait
euh peut-être allez-vous me contredire
et à trouver j'allais dire des contrats
exemple
mais mais c'est bien en tout cas je ne
vois pas comment accessoirement on peut
faire différemment quand il y a un
problématique vraiment vraiment le lien
entre l'ARS et le préfet sur ces sujets
là il est nécessaire et et le lien entre
le préfet je vis dire même l'ARS et les
collectivités
territoriales il se fait aussi il est
nécessaire
aussi le Président je crois re bondir je
me permets une dernière question je dis
pas qu'oneviendra pas sur l'eau il faut
que je recherche un peu de documentation
sur sur ce qu'on je me redocumente sur
sur ce qu'on avait Poé comme différence
mais vous avez un peu esquivé la la
question qui était celle de de
l'autorité publique en matière de
maîtrise du foncier de l'orientation de
l'usage des sols sur ces
périmètres si vous ne le faites pas qui
le fera je veux dire enfin c'est euh
c'est voilà c'est c'est une question de
droit rural hein c'est c'est la question
de bon voilà on peut pas dire qu'il y a
pas de sujet puisque on est dans une on
va vers des impasses extrêmement
importantes moi je vrais vous poser une
dernière question
euh on a senti dans l'Assemblée
nationale dans les parties prenantes de
la société civile et même dans
l'expression du ministre de
l'Agriculture une forme d'ambigué sur la
loi de 2014 qui a donné
àaness un un pouvoir
important un pouvoir quasiment une toute
petite dérogation sur le temps hein mais
quant aux a même quant aux autorisation
de mise sur le marché bon on a senti une
hésitation bon est-ce que pouvez nous
dire clairement la position du ministère
de la Santé en la matière est-ce que le
ministère de la Santé est pour le
maintien dans le code de la santé
publique très clairement des
prérogatives attribuées en 2014 à l'ANS
en matière d'autorisation des produits
euh ou est-ce qu'il laisserait faire le
cas échéant une remise en cause de ses
pouvoir
merci la réponse que je vais vous faire
c'est d'abord vous dire que l'anè et
pour être aller visiter des laboratoires
notamment laboratoire de Nancy
euh parce que c'est bien aussi de
d'aller voir pour pour comprendre
produit une expertise indépendante je
crois qu'il est important de le signaler
et de haut niveau scientifique euh et là
aussi pour prendre décision on a besoin
d'avoir
euh des des des des résultats qui soient
scientifiquement établis donc c'est vrai
qu'elle est souvent en difficulté quand
à la mobilisation de l'expertise
notamment en raison de sa volonté de
maintenir une intransigence constante
contre les conflits d'intérêts mais je
le répète que l'anè bien une expertise
indépendante et de haut niveau
scientifique et pour pour prendre des
décisions et là aussi la crise sanitaire
nous a montré à quel point nous avons
besoin aussi d'avoir des la place de la
science et de remettre la place de la
science à son bon niveau l'anè est là
pour ça et pour répondre précisément à
ma question donc pas de remise en cause
de la loi 2014 et conforation de de l'an
16 dans ses prérogatives en matière
d'autorisation mise sur le marché à ce
stade pour moi
oui merci monsieur le rapporteur maci je
rebondis sur deux trois points
avant qu'on on élargisse l'échange au
mom de la Commission sur pardonnez-moi
je je ne vous me prenez pas il y a
vraiment rien de personnel dans les
propos c'est pour aller au fond des
choses et en plus de ça je parle à la
ministre mais je pense que dans d'autres
fonctions en tant ancien élu vous verrez
ce que je veux dire on est souvent
confronté s'agissant d'examiner la
conduite des politiques publiques à des
constats à la panglos tout va pour le
mieux dans le meilleur des mondes
possible pardonnez-moi mais c'est un
petit peu l'impression que vous m'avez
donné quand on a abordé la question
l'interministérielle bien sûr qu'il
existe des relations bien sûr c'est pas
pour ça que l'Inter ministériel est
satisfaisant je vais vous donner un
exemple on audisionne on auditionne les
administration de contrôle on découvre
que la DGCCRF en application
parfaitement rigoureuse et scrupuleuse
de la loi recense un taux de noncformité
sur les produits mis en marché qui est
impressionnant et qui en médiia vis-àvis
du grand public est
indéfendable et qui serait absolument
inadmissible dans le domaine de la
pharmacie on parleant santé la question
se pose du durcissement des sanctions
vous avez vous-même dit en faisant
référence à la phytopharmacovigilance
qu'il faudrait avoir un niveau
d'exigence sur la vigilance des produits
mis en marché en matière de produits
phytopharmaceutiques qui soit comparable
vous avez dit en ancienne pharmacienne
j'en témoigne à l'exigence de rigueur de
de de de
d'exemplarité de tous les acteurs y
compris privés qui mettent en marché
proposent à accompagne les usages de
produits qui par ailleurs peuvent être
dangereux s'ils ne sont pas utilisés
dans les conditions qui sont très très
strictement très rigoureusement définies
par des autorités par ailleurs diplôé
sanctionné et cetera sur un cas comme ça
est-ce que l'interministériel
actuelle vous permet comme ministre de
la Santé d'échanger avec votre homologue
à Bery sur la cohérence de ce qui est en
vigueur en matière de contrôle et de
l'exigence que vous vous portez en
matière de santé publique
c'est là qu' a un défaut
d'interministériel il suffit absolument
pas de mettre en relation les services
encore parle si on reprend l'exemple des
périmètres entre les ARS et les agences
de l'eau nous avons auditionné des
agences de l'eau qui nous disent sur la
définition des périmètres nous nous
heurtons à des ARS qui en application
d'un texte parle de l'adjectif
accidentel alors que nous nous
parlonsadjectif
diffuse en fait en matière de santé nous
sommes d'accord et en application des
textes nous ne pouvons rien faire enfin
c'est quand même là pardonnez-moi je le
dis avec passion je suis sûr que
l'ancien élu que vous êtes voit très
bien ce que je veux dire il faut
dépasser le respect des procédures qui
permet à chacun de dire je fais
correctement mon métier mais à la fin de
ne pas atteindre le résultat de la
politique publique et de l'intention du
législateur donc
l'interministériel là vous nous avez
parlé je vous pose la question autrement
d'une
qui réunir les administrations centrales
concerné quelle disposition pensez-vous
prendre pour que il ne soit pas mis en
place une administration centrale qui
aura sa propre feuille de route et qui
ne travaillera ni conjointement ni
solidairement avec les
autres al d'abord l'élu que que j'étais
je Peret de dire que je suis toujours
élu donc je suis
toujours
je je crois que la réponse à votre
question elle vient dans la la réponse
que j'ai faite tout à l'heure à Monsieur
à Monsieur
potier tout d'abord quand j'ai parlé
d'interministérialité je vous ai pas
cité les les administrations je vous ai
cité les ministres et je vous ai cité
les élus je le redis c'est une volonté
que nous avons et quand j'échange bien
sûr nos administrations échangent bien
sûr nos conseil échange mais nous
échangeons aussi entre ministrre quand
je vous quand je vous parle
d'interministérialité je vous ai bien
parlé
des ministres et et je vous redis ma
volonté c'est bien à travers ce comité
interministériel dont je vous ai parlé
et vous remarquerez puisque je sais que
vous avez été très attentif que je n'ai
pas parlé
uniquement du ministère de la Santé de
l'agriculture de l'écologie et de la
recherche j'ai cité aussi le ministère
de l'Économie et dans mon propos
liminire quand je vous ai parlé du plan
haut tout à l'heure je vous ai aussi
citer le ministère de l'Industrie donc
ce ce ce sujet il est profondément
interministériel et quand je vous dis
que ma volonté de monter la Brig 2 et de
de de de
pouvoir créer ce ce comité
interministériel c'est bien parce que je
pense qu'il nous faut avoir cette cette
entitélà pour qu'ensemble on puisse
j'allais dire non seulement avoir la
cohérence dont dont que vous appelez de
vos veut mais cette obligation de
résultats en terme de santé publique
dont nous sommes tous
redevables euh dans le Pr j'ai une autre
question dans le prolongement de de
alors pardonnez-moi jeis je fais juste
un commentaire sur votre réponse je ne
doute absolument pas de votre sincérité
je ne doute absolument pas de vos
efforts je ne doute absolument pas de
votre
engagement permettez-moi quand même de
constater que le compte n est pas la
France ne sait pas bien faire
l'interministère et en matière de
politique publique particulièrement sur
des résultats qui relèvent de plusieurs
administrations centrales nous ne sommes
pas bons il s'agit d'un interministériel
à mettre en place il s'agit de réunion à
laquelle se rendent des fonctionnaires
qui vont se dire les contours de mon
poste avant et après la réunion vont
bouger je ne ferai pas exactement la
même chose c'est pas de la mise en
commun c'est pas des arbitrages expost
c'est pas des mises en relation
indispensable évidemment qui ont lieu
c'est une redéfinition des
responsabilités de chaque
pour que on ne se retrouve pas avec des
respects de procédure qui se substituent
à de l'atteinte de résultat et je
maintiens que votre réponse pour pour
sincère
et que je prends comme telle de ce point
de vue là concrètement pour moi me
laisse sur ma fin sur la question de
cette cohésion entre différents
organismes là je parle d'organisme de
scientifique vous le savez c'est un
point qu'on a beaucoup abordé dans la
Commission d'
enquête les disputes au sens
étymologique du terme entre différentes
autorités sont un vecteur dévastateur en
matière de
confiance si plusieurs autorités ne sont
pas d'accord entre elles et entre
guillemets lavent leur Ling salle
publiquement c'est dévastateur pour la
confiance que peuvent accorder les
profanes que nous sommes tous sur des
questions complexes et très techniques
et d'une une grande complexité
scientifique qu'est vous mettez en uvre
pour garantir cette cohérence cette
cohésion dans la communication entre
l'iner l'
et nous avons toutes les semaines toutes
les 4 matins des témoignages de
scientifi nous en avons même reçu qui
font part
d'études que nous avons auun aucune
raison de remettre en cause qui on les
compét qui obtiennent des résultats qui
remettent en
cause
l'exercice des prérogatives de ces trois
institutions dont je vous ai parlé
qu'est-ce que vous mettez en œuvre pour
que les autorités scientifiques
publiques j'insiste Inserm an FFSA
communique la même chose font part de la
transparence et de l'interdisciplinarité
de la collégialité qui garantissent que
la contradiction scientifique peut leur
être apportée qu'elle est prise en
compte dans les procédures de manière à
rassurer en fait le les citoyens et les
consommateurs là je fais référence à la
distinction entre danger et risque la
référence entre la différence entre
analyse et gestion du risque et la
différence entre cette notion qui est
très troublante de toxicologie
réglementaire qui s'opposerait la
toxicologie réelle comme on oppose le
pays légal au pays
réel pour essayer de finir de de vous
convaincre pas seulement sur ma bonne
foi mais non seulement sur ma volonté
aussi sur la
première partie de la réponse et pour
être montrer que c'est pas uniquement
une bonne volonté du ministère de la
santé mais c'est quelque chose qui est
fortement porté aussi par la première
ministre
euh vous dire que le secrétariat général
de la planification écologique a aussi
ce rôle de faire travailler en inter en
interministérialité et c'est le cas et
c'est le cas puisque régulièrement
autour de la planification
écologique les différents ministères euh
travaille aussi sur ce sujet et donc des
facto il y a aussi la santé puisque la
planification écologique du système de
santé euh est aussi un enjeu majeur et
je vais vous dire que 8 % des émissions
de gaz effet sper sont fait par le sont
produites par la santé donc c'est aussi
vous montrer que l'interministérialité
sur tous ces sujets sont sont pris en
compte
euh après en ce qui concerne le le
ministère de de la santé vous évoquez
ces trois ces trois agences et et
j'entends vous parler vous parler de de
confiance dans mon propos liminire j'ai
marqué j'ai parlé de pragmatisme et de
transparence d'abord moi je suis
intimement convaincu que la confiance
vient aussi de la transparence sur tous
ces sujets et ça se construit aussi
aussi comme ça sur les agences
auxquelles vous avez fait vous avez fait
allusion d'abord dire que ces agences
sont indépendantes je le redis elles
nous apportent j'allais dire des
résultats et des préconisations euh
après c'est bien avec le directeur
général de la santé que nous nous
prenons les décisions et les
orientations en fonction j'allais dire
des recommandations émises par par ces
agences alors vous avez parlé de rapport
moi je parle du rapport bénéfice risque
euh il s'agit toujours de mesurer euh
voilà et quand on parle de
l'eau il est aussi parfois difficile
d'expliquer que l'eau est potable et
elle l' et il faut le dire même si nous
savons que dans l'eau il y a des
produits mais pas une Vmax qui qui
permet de dire qu'elle est potable faut
aussi avoir un langage de transparence
j'allais dire faire aussi de la
pédagogie sur ce tout ce que cela veut
dire je crois que c'est important et et
en ce qui
concerne je je le redis la confiance la
confiance viendra aussi de la
transparence et de la pédagogie que nous
aurons envers nos concitoyens qui sont
de
qui sont demandeurs sur tous ces sujets
là rapport bénéfice risque expliquer
expliquer ce qui se ce qui se passe
pourquoi quelle
conséquence toujours à la lumière d'une
expertise scientifique je crois que
c'est aussi
important merci Madame la Ministre
j'ouvre les échanges m de la commission
madame
babo merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la ministre pour votre votre
présence j'ai effectivement plusieurs
questions alors monsieur le rapporteur
évoquait la question importante de la
pollution de l'eau et sur La Rochelle
nous avons fermé 15 captages récemment
donc je ne peux souscrire je je souscris
totalement à l'inquiétude des riverins
et à la nécessité de les protéger le
plus possible et j'aimerais évoquer la
pollution de l'air puisque
malheureusement mon territoire est aussi
concerné
par différents différents phyos dans
l'air mais notamment le
proculfocarbe et sur sur la pollution de
l'air le niveau d'analyse est moins
important que que les analyses qu'on
peut avoir sur l'eau donc j'aimerais
avoir ce ce votre regard sachant que il
me semble que les agents satmo ont
besoin de moyens supplémentaires donc
avoir votre regard sur ce sujet
deuxièmement évoquer le registre des
cancers au niveau national aujourd'hui
la France n'a pas de reg registre
national détaillé donc savoir si c'est
un projet et avoir votre point de
vue troisème chose
sur est-ce que est-ce que vous avez une
visibilité sur la part des phyos sur
l'impact sur la santé et plus largement
peut-être la totalité des pollutions
c'està-dire de manière un peu macro sur
100% apparemment ça existe sur certaines
j'étais avec l'ARS Laars lundi qui me
donnait quelques éléments sur sur la sur
l'eau donc peut-être qu'on a quelques
éléments sur sur plus large et dernière
question ou dernière remarque c'est sur
la
Parkinson une personne sur 50 sera
touchée dans sa vie par cette maladie
neurodégénérative qui progresse sur
Alzheimer il y a eu de il y a eu des
plans de mis en place sur Parkinson non
euh voilà c'est j'ai déposé des
amendements récemment sur le SU sujet
qui n'ont pas eu un grand écho
j'aimerais voilà j'aimerais avoir votre
regard sur ce qui va être mis en place
sur cette maladie qui touche les
agriculteur mais pas queux et d'ailleurs
je pense que les vendeurs de produits
phytopharmaceutiques pourraient être
concernés par la maladie
professionnelle il a des méthodes
différentes parfois on prend plusieurs
questions de plusieurs députés donc je
je je m'adapte euh merci d'avoir parlé
du sujet de l'air euh qu' qu'on n'oublie
pas qu'on n'oublie pas on est bien là
ici dans dans l'objet de la surveillance
réglementaire des pesticid HE dans l'air
euh là aussi vous dire et c'est pas
évacuer le sujet d' d'un d'un revers de
main qu' à propos de ces produits
phytosanitaires là aussi ce sujet se
travaille en interministériel et que le
ministère de la santé n'est pas le seul
compétent euh le chef de fil sur l'air
c'est le ministère chargé de
l'environnement euh néanmoins les
conséquences de la présence des
pesticides sont sur la santé et c'est
bien s pour cela que c'est un sujet
interministériel
euh vous vous l'avez fait
mais ici saluez le travail des
associations
agré sur la surveillance de la qualité
de l'air et
atmorance qui se mobilise pour étudier
de la présence des pesticides dans l'air
dans un contexte où cette présence n'est
pas encore
réglementée
je parle bien de la p la présence des
pesticides dans
l'air dans toujours notre volonté
d'améliorer nos
connaissances on prend également en
compte l'exposition via le compartiment
r nous devons ainsi renforcer notre
expective collective pour demain être en
mesure de réglementer tout cela sur des
bases
solide dès 2024 un état des lieux des
différents dispositifs de surveillance
des produits pH pharmaaceutique dans
l'environnement et dans l'air sera
réalisé par les administrations
compétentes en s'appuyant sur des
travaux notamment et récemment mené par
l'inerbe Line raé et l'reem afin
d'identifier les voies éventuelles de
progrès y compris pour les substances
qui ne sont plus utilisés mais qui
seront toujours présentes dans les
milieux ainsi que les produits de
transformation des substances dans euh
dans
l'environnement bien que c'est un sujet
important
euh
sur le registre des cancers
euh il y a une PPL qui a été discutée au
Sénat
euh la réponse qui a été apportée sur ce
sujet par le le gouvernement c'est de
dire que l'INC déjà faisait un grand
travail n'a pas
complètement
euh le gouvernement av mis un avis de
sagesse euh sur ce sujet sur cette
proposition de loi euh
l'UNC qui travaille beaucoup sur ce
sujet donct on peut saluer j'allais dire
la qualité euh des travaux elle
proposait de s'appuyer plutôt sur le
système national des données de santé
plutôt que de recréer un registre des
cancers donc vous savez à quel point je
suis très attentif au travail
parlementaire et donc nous aurons de
nouveau ici ce débat si cette PPL euh
arrive à l'Assemblée nationale elle a
été débatue il y a quelques mois au
Sénat vous donnez un pourcentage sur la
part des produits phytosanitaires et et
l'impact sur la santé serait bien
imprudent de ma part serait bien
imprudent de ma part et je vais pas me
lancer dans cette
affaire parce que je ne suis pas sûr que
d'ailleurs personne puisse le faire donc
je ne le ferai pas euh peut-être est-
quelque chose et des indicateurs qu'il
nous faut qu'il nous faut un jour
développé mais je viens de vous dire
qu'on n pas tout à fait et qu'on n pas
en mesure de mesurer les pesticides dans
l'air qui peut-être sont responsables
sans aucun doute pour certains d'entre
eux de pathologie ça veut dire que ceuxl
on sait pas encore les vraiment bien les
mesurer donc je serais vraiment très
imprudent de ma part de de de de me
lancer sur la réponse à votre question
qui était très générale euh on sait
qu'il y a un impact et on le voit bien
puisqu'on parle de différentes
pathologies euh vous dire quel
pourcentage cela représente sur la santé
euh je ne le sais pas et je ne sais pas
si quelqu'un est en mesure de pouvoir
faire ce genre j'allais dire d'étude euh
sans oublier quelque chose d'ailleurs
euh sur la maladie de de Parkinson sur
laquelle vous avez euh vous avez attiré
l'attention là bien sûr dans le cadre de
la prise en charge via le fond euh mais
l'objet c'est bien aussi de faire de la
prévention euh de la prévention auprès
euh des des utilisateurs de ces produits
auprès des anciens utilisateurs de ces
produits et puis peut-être aussi et vous
l'avez fait d'ailleurs accessoirement
remarquer auprès de toutes les personnes
euh qui sont pas forcément utilisateurs
mais qui ont notamment vendu tous ces
produits et peut-être les populations
autour donc la prévention est sans doute
la mre de toutes les batailles dans ce
domaine j'ai répondu à toutes les
questions ou
pas vous avez une question sur les
captages
non non non sur les sur les captages
c'était juste pour voilà pour rebondir
sur ce que Monsieur rapporteur disait
sur la sur les statisties sur les
pollutions les différentes pollutions
j'en conviens c'est effectivement très
complexe je sais pas si un jour on
pourra donner ce type d'élément il y a
parfois quelques chiffres qui ressortent
mais ça serait effectivement très
complexe mais ça met quand même le doigt
sur le fait fait qu'aujourd'hui voilà
les riverins s'inquiètent de certaines
de certaines pollutions notamment de
l'impact des
phyos sur sur leur santé on le voit sur
les clusters pédiatriques enfin moi j'ai
j'ai le cas sur ma circo voilà mais il
faut aussi prendre en compte qu'il y a
d'autres pollutions dans notre quotidien
et sur Parkinson vous parliez de
prévention sur la Parkinson vous parliez
de prévention mais il y a aussi
d'accompagner aujourd'hui les malades
qui sont ce qui est mal fait à mon sens
il y a vrai sujet je pense là-dessus
merci en tout cas pour vos réponses sur
sur tout à l'heure la l'objet c'est
phyosignal développé alors jeai pas je
l'ai pas nommé comme ça puisqu'on n'est
pas encore tout à fait borné sur le nom
mais de pouvoir signaler j'allais dire
toute compag toute contamination tout
toute
euh toute présomption ou toute
phyosignal c'est quelque chose qu'on
doit développer on va y mettre des
moyens puisqu'on va mettre 2 millions
euh 2 millions d'euros sur sur sur ce
système j'allais dire qui doit nous
aussi nous mettre en alerte euh et ça
c'est quelque chose qui est
attendu de la part des associations mais
de la part aussi de de nos concitoyens
et c'est un objet dont il faudra nous
saisir peut-être qui nous permettra non
pas de faire des statistiques aussi
aussi précis mais au moins d'avoir
d'avoir une idée donc c'est une volonté
j'allais dire là aussi de mettre un
outil à disposition pour pouvoir être le
réceptacle de tout voilà et pour
reparler de Parkinson puisque vous avez
fait allusion à la prévention et au
suivi là aussi la mobilisation et
l'information des professionnels de
santé doit être importante c'est bien
pour ça qu'on a aussi j'allais dire pour
ambition et pour le coup là c'est de la
compétence du ministère de la Santé de
travailler sur ce
sujet merci Madame la Ministre madame
Thomas merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre merci pour vos propos
j'ai trois sujets sur lesquels je
souhaitais vous
interroger le premier concerne les
effets cocktail des des pesticides les
auditions menées dans le cadre de cette
commission ont mis à jour la question de
l'effet cocktail et du manque de
connaissance à ce sujet quels moyens
sont mis en œuvre pour approfondir la
recherche à ce sujet et
protéger les moyens des conséquences
négatives de l'effet cocktail
ma
deuxème thématique concerne les plans
écofyo on en a un petit peu parler tout
à l'heure vous étiez présente le 31
octobre à l'annonce de la stratégie
écofito 2030 pour représenter le
ministère de la Santé vous avez tout à
l'heure esquissé le rôle du ministère
dans l'impulsion de de cette nouvelle
stratégie je voulais connaître plus
précisément le rôle du ministère de la
Santé dans l'élaboration et la mise en
œuvre des plans écopito de quels
éléments êtes-vous à l'initiative et
comment est-ce piloter il y a une vraie
question autour de des évolutions de
gouvernance en matière de plan écopyo
est-ce que vous êtes davantage acteurs
dans ce nouveau plans et puis depuis le
début des plans écofyo quels arbitrages
le ministère de la Santé a-t-il perdu au
sein de ce gouvernement notamment face à
des ministères comme ceux que vous avez
cité tout à l'heure celui de
l'agriculture celui de l'industrie et à
l'inverse bien sûr quels arbitrages
avez-vous remporté dans le cadre
d'échang de travail interministériel
avec vos collègues des autres ministères
plus globalement c'est peut-être une
question un peu plus franché directe qui
décide dans ses plans écofyau au sein
des différents ministères ou qui a la
main et enfin je souhaitais vous
interroger sur le sujet du
glyphosate puisque la France va
s'abstenir en Conseil de l'Union
européenne sur le renouvellement pour 10
ans de l'autorisation du glyphosate pour
rappel en 2018 la France s'était opposée
à ce renouvellement je voulais savoir
quels ont été les préconisation de la
part de votre ministère pour faire
évoluer ce choix de la France vers une
abstention et euh ma collègue a très
bien parlé euh de la maladie de
Parkinson alors je voulais aussi
prolonger euh ce questionnement
concernant le glyphosate puisqu'il
existe un lien de cause à effet entre la
contamination par le glyphosate et le
développement de cette maladie euh vous
avez parlé de votre action en matière de
prévention pour l'utilisation aussi
enfin pour les utilisateurs pour ceux
qui vendent euh et bien des produits
comme le glyphosate en tant que
représentant du ministère de la Santé
prenez-vous au sein du gouvernement la
position de l'opposition au
renouvellement et au vu de la
dangerosité de certains produits
phytosanitaires comme le glyphosate sur
la santé humaine quel est selon vous
l'influence ou la responsabilité de
votre ministère pour accompagner et
faire reconnaître au mieux les malades
et les victimes de ces produits
phytosanitaires vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure vous avez un travail
interministériel est-ce que votre
influence est suffisante face aux autres
ministères en
particulier se représentant le monde de
l'industrie et de l'agriculture je vous
remercie alors sur la première question
concernant les effets les effets
cocktails tout d'abord l'enjeu et vous
l'avez dit l'enjeu autour des effets
cocktails c'est d'apprendre et de mieux
connaître euh en fonction des
expositions ce à quoi il est possible ou
ce à quoi malheureusement nous sommes
exposés sur le volet de la surveillance
de la
phytopharmacovigilance qui est à mon
avis l'enjeu et je le redis c'est un
enjeu important la
phytopharmacovigilance euh j'en parlais
tout à l'heure dans le propos
introductif faudra veiller à renforcer
notre action à celle de l'anè si nous
vlons mieux connaître les risques liés à
l'exposition mais auss au cumul des
Exposition effet cocktail ou effet dose
euh il faudra être en mesure de savoir
quel produit
je dis bien quel produit a été utilisé
dans quelle quantité et à quel endroit
ça fait beaucoup de connaissance sur
lequel nous devons avoir des réponses
afin de mieux connaître l'effet cocktail
aujourd'hui cela est réglementairement
prévu mais avec la nouvelle stratégie
ecyo 2030 nous viendrons améliorer ces
recueils d'informations notamment je le
redis en numérisant le processus il faut
bien que pour mesurer et savoir quels
sont à la fois les effets cocktail ou
les effets dose avoir la réponse à ces à
ces trois questions quel produit quelle
quantité quel endroit euh vous redire
que ces effets cocktails aussi l'étude
Esteban permet déjà de de prendre
connaissance de ces sujets notamment
avec une première cororte qui a permis
de mesurer l'exposition des Français à
cinq familles de pesticides euh bien je
le redis hein les premiè résultats que
les niveaux d'exposition semblent
diminuer force de constater que les
niveaux d'expositions sont variables en
fonction des substances et des classes
d'âge de plus une part non négligeable
de la population était encore exposée à
ces substances
encore aujourd'hui
interdite euh la deuxème question sur le
plan écophyo du 31 10 euh vous dire que
le plan écophyo du 310 la réunion à
laquelle j'étais c'était pas la
présentation du plan écopito c'était
bien le lancement de la consultation qui
va nous permettre j'allais dire
d'aboutir au plan qui sera présenté
début
2024 et dont je le redis les travaux de
votre
euh commission et dont le rapport des
travaux de commission viendra peut-être
enrichir ce plan vous m' interrogez sur
quel a été
la la contribution du
ministère de la Santé alors je vais vous
donner six points sur lequel le
ministère de la Santé a contribué à
cette stratégie ou à ce plan écofyo
2030 déployer sur tout le territoire
national y compris en outrem l'outil de
signalement des expositions aux produits
phytopharmaceutique à l'image des outils
phytosignal ou Phytoréponse expérimenté
déjà dans certaines régions
je l'ai dit c'est 2 millions d'euros qui
seront investis dans le déploiement de
cet outil sensibiliser les
professionnels de santé à la question
des maladies professionnelles lié à
l'usage de produits phytopharmaceutiques
et à la question de l'exposition des
riverins et des personnes vulnérables
tout à l'heure on a parlé duutéro et des
femmes des femmes enceintes envisager
après une étude de faisabilité pilotée
par le ministère chargé de la santé la
possibilité de mettre en œuvre et de
financer un dispositif d'indemnisation
des riverins à l'instar de la prise en
charge des victimes prof in d'ors et
déjà prévu dans le cadre du fond
d'indemnisation dont on a parlé tout à
l'heure le fameux
fivp étudier les suites y compris
réglementaires si nécessaire à donneré
au résultats des études les plus
récentes telles que les études Go Agri
et pestive dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure à la fois au niveau national
mais aussi au niveau européen intégrer
le comité de suivi des études nationales
sur les produits phytopharmaceuniques et
la santé piloté par la DGS à la
gouvernance du plan écofyo 2030 et lui
donner une dimension plus globale one
else une seule santé monsieur le député
potier renforcer les contrôles sur la
conformité des
pulvérisateurs notamment vis-à-vis des
risques de dérive voilà quelles sont les
propositions et la contribution du
ministère de la Santé sur le sujet le
sujet euh du plan écofito qui sera
j'allais dire qui partant pour l'instant
est parti j'allais dire en consultation
donc je le redis le 3110 ça n'était pas
la présentation officielle du plan
écofito je crois qu'il est important que
ce soit dit ici dans cette commission
pour répondre à votre
interrogation sur le sujet du
glyphosate vous le savez et vous l'avez
dit ce le glyphosate fait l'objet depuis
plusieurs années de controversse quant à
ses effets sur la santé humaine il
existe notamment des divers gence entre
les instances internationales sur son
potentiel
cancérogène le Centre international de
recherche sur le cancer a ainsi classé
le glyphosate en catégorie 2A
cancérogène probable c'est dans ce
contexte qu'en 2017 le président de la
République demande de prendre les
dispositions nécessaires pour que
l'utilisation de ce glyphosate soit
interdite en France dès que des
alternatives auront été trouvé en 2019
une réévaluation au niveau européen est
lancée par un consorcium de pays membres
dont la France et de nouvelles études
sont fournies par le fabricant et
transmises à l'EC et lafsa ces
expertises ont conclu en 2022 que la
substance ne présentait pas les critères
scientifiques requis pardon pour être
classé dans la catégorie des substances
cancérogènes mutagènes ou toxiquees pour
la reproduction les fameuses CMR dont
nous avons parlé l'EFSA a complété que
l'évaluation de l'impact du glyphosate
sur la santé humaine la santé animale et
l'environnement n'avait pas identifié de
domaine de préoccupation
critique ainsi le ministère de la santé
et de la prévention est parfaitement
aligné à la position tenue par la France
à plusieurs reprises nous considérons
que le glyphosate est une substance dont
l'utilisation doit être réduite à
l'échelle européenne et limité aux
utilisations pour lesquelles il n'existe
pas
d'alternative pour toutes ces raisons
contte tenu d'abord des incertitudes
souligné par les scientifiques que je
viens de rappeler nous soutenons
pleinement la demande que la durée de
l'approbation soit beaucoup plus courte
que les 10 ans proposés et pour ces
raisons la proposition du MSP au regard
des connaissances actuelles au regard
des connaissances actuelles ainsi que
des préconisations d'usage proposé
précédemment et l'abstention sans
présager puisque la décision n'est pas
tout à fait prise de la position qui
seappter au final lors du vote tenu à la
Commission européenne je crois que c'est
de demain le 16
novembre merci Madame la Ministre Madame
éedel M votre
picro merci monsieur le Président merci
madame la ministre pour le temps que
vous nous consacré aujourd'hui j'auraiis
j'aurai plusieurs questions et et ma
première question
concerne l'usage du mot pesticide en
lien avec le mot biocide euh quelle
différence faites-vous à l'échelle du
ministère entre pesticides et et
biocides sachant que les molécules
peuvent être identiques mais les usages
différent donc de votre côté faites-vous
un traitement différent entre ces
appellations ma deuxème question
concerne le comportement de vos
homologues à l'échelle européenne sur ce
ce sujet des pesticides voire des
pesticides et des biocides dans leur
fonctionnement au quotidien en lien à
l'échelle de leur pays est-ce qu'on a
une politique on va dire plus poussée
moins poussée est-ce qu'il y a des
différences est-ce que la France a une
position plus exigeante ou pas
j'aimerais en entendre en entendre plus
par rapport à ça et quel niveau de
coopération a-t-on sur ce sujet des
pesticides je vous
remercie
alors très clairement entre pesticides
et biocides nous ne faisons pas de
différence ça je peux pas les deux ont
des conséquences sanitaires et qu'il
nous faut prendre en compte donc c'est
le rôle du ministère de la Santé que de
prendre en compte les conséquences
sanitaires sur à la fois les pesticides
et les bioydes donc pas de différence
sur ces deux sur ces deux sujets
euh
votre
question au
niveau vos deux autres questions
concernent les coopération j'allais
dire à l'échelle à l'échelle
européenne je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
dans dans nos propos dans mes propos
liminires l'enjeu bien sûr et les
décisions que nous prenons mais l'enjeu
est d'avoir j'allais dire dans
le maximum et quand c'est possible des
des positions communes au niveau
européen ça faciliterait dans beaucoup
de domaines parfois des décisions qui
sont difficiles à comprendre
euh par nos concitoyens par nos
concitoyens donc l'enjeu de des échanges
réguliers que nous devons avoir sur ces
sujets avec nos partenaires européens il
est important euh il est important aussi
parfois dans les réflexions souvent dans
dans les réflexions et dans l'expertise
je dire partager nos niveaux de recherch
euh sur les sujets est aussi intéressant
et important et de savoir et de
comprendre pourquoi parfois nous
n'arrivons pas forcément aux même aux
mêmes conclusions donc comme dans
beaucoup d'autres domaines je crois que
la coopération européenne est nécessaire
que nous avons des échanges réguliers
avec nos homologues et
que l'enjeu mais ce ce cette réponse
vaut pour j'allais dire presque tous les
domaines et d'avoir le plus possible des
positions assez assez
uniformes pour j'allis dire là aussi la
confiance de nos concitoyens sur ces
sujets vient aussi que nous expliquion
qu'il n'y ait pas ou le moins possible
de différence avec nos homologues
européen euh et sur sur ces sujets là on
voit aussi l'importance et puisque j'ai
eu l'occasion de faire notamment dans le
cadre de la transition écologique du
système de santé d'avoir des échanges au
niveau européen il y a quelques mois
euh là aussi le le partage et le retour
d'expérience est aussi intéressant et
important pour prendre des décisions et
aller voir ce qui se fait ailleurs est
toujours aussi important comme nos
omologues européens viennent aussi voir
ce qu'on fait et quelle décision on
prend chez nous donc le partage et le
retour d'expérience et j'ai dis essayer
d'arriver au maximum à des positions
uniformes serait important pour la
confiance merci madame la ministre il
nous reste encore suffisamment de temps
mais on pourra peut-être faire une
suspension euh j'en profite pour vous
poser une question qui anecdotique en
réalité mais qui peut être emblématique
euh il a été conduit lors de la
mandature précédente une une
expérimentation
par la direction générale de l'offre de
soins du service ministère de la Santé
une expérimentation qui s'appelle repas
à l'hôpital et qui est la conduite une
expérimentation en trois établissements
de santé permettant de d'atteindre les
objectifs de la première loi égaline du
titre 2 dans la restauration collective
à
l'hôpital ma question c'est un est-ce
que vous avez entendu parler de cette
expérimentation de si si vous en avez
entendu parler comment expliquez-vous
qu'il n'en a été donné aucune
suite 3 est-ce
que vos
services se sentent concernés par le
fait qu'il a une implication
parlementaire sur cette expérimentation
enurrence en plus c'est moi qui
superviser le truc et est-ce qu'il est
prévu qu'il rende compte des décisions
qui vont être prises pour donner suite
ou pas à cette expérimentation là on est
vraiment dans la concrétisation d'une
loi
dans un cas particulier qui est la
restauration collective à
l'hôpital je répondre très franchement à
la première
question la réponse est si j'ai je suis
au courant de cette expéentation la
réponse est non donc je vais m'en
requérir de rchef par contre je vais
quand même répondre à à l'objet et et de
cette de cette problématique qui a été
levé par l'expérimentation et vous dire
qu'on a des travaux qui vont dans ce
centre dans dans deux dans deux sujets
tout d'abord dans le cadre de la snan
euh la stratégie nationale
d'alimentation nutrition climat euh qui
est en cours d'élaboration euh sur
lequel là aussi un travail
interministériel important est en train
d'être mené et puis dans le cadre de la
planification écologique du système de
santé où un des objets et un des
chantiers sur lequels nous travaillons
et nous travaillons avec les
établissements j'allais dire
hospitaliers et médicaux-sociaux c'est
la politique d'achat durable euh et
quand je dis d'achat durable ça comporte
j'allais dire tout euh tout ce qui va
autour de du repas euh du repas à
l'hôpital puisque un volet dans le cadre
de de la transition écologique du
système de santé est consacré à
l'alimentation donc deux chantiers sont
sont lancés sur cette sur cette
thématique la snan et euh la transition
écologique la transition écologique du
système de santé sur laquelle je
réunirai le 15 décembre le 2e comité de
pilotage euh sur laquelle une feuille de
route euh a été euh établie et je ne
manquerai pas de revenir vers vous euh
j'allais dire sur la question précise
euh que vous avez posé à laquelle à
l'instant où je vous parle je n'ai pas
la réponse merci de votre réponse je me
permet juste de vous faire observer
avant de de de suspendre nos travaux
pour 10 minutes monsieur le rapporteur
un truc à dire que je trouve quand même
confondant que tant la stratégie
nationale soit élaborée que le deuxième
chantier sur lequel vous travaillez soit
piloté par vos services avec cette
expérimentation qui a été conduite sans
que le Parlement soit enformé en aucune
manière alors que j'ai encore une fois
supervisé cette expérimentation et sans
que les acteurs qui l'ont conduite je
pense à restoco ne soit aucunement
impliqué sans aucune conceration avec
les acteurs qui concrètement pilotent
les cuisine en restauration autogérée
dans les hôpitaux je trouve ça madame la
ministre confondant
monsieur le rapporteur
oui c'est le président qui qui m'inspire
cette question
sur il y a les politiques publiques sur
sur l'agroécologie le PSN la PAC on va
pas vous poser des questions là-dessus
on va les réserver pour les ministres de
l'Agriculture bien sûr mais je ne doute
pas que votre votre mobilisation pourra
peut-être infléchir les les les
penchants qui sont les leurs dans les
arbitrages à venir pour la révision du
plan stratégique national qui a été un
faible levier sinon un levier inefficace
jusqu'à présent
moi je voudrais par
contre vous interroger sur une politique
publique qui relève de de de
l'alimentation tout toute notre idée
c'est comment on aide les agriculteurs à
bâtir des stratégies agroécologiques qui
permettent de s'affranchir des phyos
mais c'est comment également crée un
marché l'alimentation qui qui tire vers
le haut c'est affranchissement des des
phyau or question question générale
madame la ministre vous avez une forte
ambition en matière de santé
environnementale c'est l'air c'est au
c'est le sol c'est c'est tout ça bien
sûr mais c'est d'abord l'alimentation
est-ce que en matière de moyens
public de de de publicité publique enfin
de d'information
publique vous admettez que les moyens
que nous mettons en œuvre
aujourd'hui pas seulement réglementair
dans les Galim mais les questions
d'information d'éducation à la santé
alimentation sont ridicules par rapport
à ce que déploie la puissance
privée
j'essaie de comprendre la question déjà
avant d'y
répondre parce que je pense que la chute
de la question n'était pas tout à fait
ce vers quoi vous avez commencé mais je
vais essayer d'y répondre je vais je
vais d'abord
répondre non non mais je crois que j'ai
compris c'est le rapport financier moyen
public de la différence des moyens entre
le privé et le public
oui pardon pour pour la confusion je
vais essayer de reformer il y a deux
grands moyens pour pour orienter
l'agriculture et qu'elle s'affranchisse
des phyau c'est les politiques publiques
d'aide à la production c'est le
planatgique nationale la PAC c'est pas
trop votre sujet par contre vous êtes au
cœur du sujet de l'alimentation avec la
DGAL et le ministère de
l'Agriculture ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui c'est que les indicateurs
tout tout ce qui tout ce qui va être les
prescriptions aux consommateurs aux
citoyens qui sont fait sont
essentiellement privés et très peu
public en matière de de santé or si on n
pas une politique
de l'alimentation soutenue par une
grande ambition de santé publique on ne
tira pas on ne pourra pas tirer vers le
haut
l'agriculture et l'aider à s'affranchir
de ses dépendances à laal chimie
actuelle et ses conséquences sur la
santé est-ce que ma question est plus
claire pour rpondre pour répondre tout à
l'heure
plutôt sur la mobilisation et la
consultation d'abord dire que la snan
elle est encore en train d' d'être
élaboré vous dire que toutes les
instances dans lesquelles des
parlementaires siègent ont été consulté
je pense notamment au Conseil national
de l'alimentation par exemple qui
travaille sur le
sujet de de la
snan et en ce qui concerne la Fédération
la planification écologique du système
de
santé là pour le coup le travail il est
interministériel et il est très
largement ouvert à toutes les
associations à toutes les fédérations
hospitalières c'est pas quelque chose
que nous faisons tout seul euh ce serait
d'ailleurs euh une grave une grave
erreur euh sur les moyens euh mis euh
j'allais dire pour euh informer nos
concitoyens euh d'abord vous l'avez
rappelé ce sujet la de l'alimentation
est piloté par le ministère de
l'agriculture vient la DGAL mais vous
dire que là aussi nous avons une
attention particulière euh sur tous les
impact euh j'allais dire de la qualité
entre guillemets euh de de
l'alimentation sur la santé ça fait
objet là je le redis des travaux que
nous menons dans le cadre de la snan que
nous menons dans le cadre du plan
national des fameux PNNS euh et là aussi
ces travaux se font très clairement en
in ministériel peut-être le meilleur des
exemples c'est celui du nutriscore
euh sur lequel nous avons eu des
échanges euh parfois difficile mais sur
laquelle nous avons réussi à trouver un
accord avec le
ministère de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation là aussi le rapport
bénéfice
risque le rapport sur la santé est
quelque chose qui nous emporte et sur
lequel on doit être j'allais dire en
tant que ministère de la santé et de la
prévention vigilant et nous le sommes à
tous les niveaux parce que vous parle on
parle des problématiques sur la santé on
peut parler des problématiques sur
l'obésité bien au-delà des
problématiques des présences des
produits utilisés dans le cadre de de
l'agriculture sur la santé de nos
concitoyens puisque vous êtes une grande
adepte et militante de l'intermin
interministérielle est-ce que vous
pourriez nous dire peut-être dans dans
dans les dans dans les jours qui
viennent le total des sommes publiques
en interministériel qui sont consacré à
l'information à l'éducation santé sur
l'alimentation et et nous dire vous êtes
une observatrice de de de la vie en
les moyens qui sont consacrés par la
publicité par ailleurs sur cette même
alimentation c'est un ratio qui nous
intéresse et si vous pouvez nous aider à
le constituer il serait une pièce
importante pour notre rapport et un
encouragement à votre ambition je vais
vous poser deux dernières questions très
rapidement qui peut-être demanderont une
réflexion et la première demandera une
réflexion c'est est-ce que vous avez
chiffré il y a un chiffrage dans lescito
30 sur le coût de la pollution de l'eau
par les phyos on est assez décontenancé
par la faiblesse de ce coup qui est
enadiction avec d'autres coups mais ça
c'est d'autres ministres que nous
interrogerons notamment Christophe Béchu
la semaine prochaine par contre sur le
coup santé humaine est-ce qu'on a une
approche un début d'approche au
ministère de la Santé je j'imagine pas
qu'il en soit autrement de dire le cût
en matière de de santé publique de
l'effet des des
pesticides et puis la dernière question
puisque on doit faire une pause et que
le temps est désormais contraint c'est
celui de l'hypothèse de créer un ordre
des f thâtre comme vous êtes
pharmacienne vous voyez de quoi il
s'agit hein c'est toutes les personnes
qui seraient amené à commercialiser à
recommander à conseiller des produits
phytopharmaceutiques devrai faire partie
d'un ordre qui se poserait un niveau de
formation qui supposerait un contrôle
collectif et et un dialogue avec la
puissance publique en la matière est-ce
qu'une telle proposition qui a déjà
cours dans certains pays
pourrait pourrait
éventuellement bénéficier de votre
soutien merci
alors vous l'avez dit vous-même le
chiffrage j'allais
dire des conséquences de la pollution de
l'eau vous avez eu du mal à le faire on
sait très bien qu'il est difficile dans
le cadre du Plan haut il y a eu un objet
une tentative de réévaluation je crois
qu'on parle de 2
milliards mais mais c'est assez
difficile parce qu'il y a aussi tout ce
que les collectivités territorial oui
toutes les collectivités territoriales
investissent euh c'est c'est pas si
facile que ça à
reconstituer
l'investissement sur la pollution sur la
pollution de l'eau sur la création d'un
ordre ce qui serait intéressant c'est de
voir comment ça fonctionne et quel est
l'impact de la création de cet ordre
dans les pays où ça existe très
honnêtement j'ai pas d'avis sur j'ai pas
d'avis sur la question ce qui
m'intéresserait de voir pour le coup
c'est de faire du benchmark mais n doute
que vous l'avez sans doute fait c'est
d'aller voir comment ça se passe dans
les pays et quels sont les résultats euh
quels sont les résultats obtenus par la
création euh de cet ordre je ne suis pas
sûr que euh vous avez mis le même plan
que l'ordre dont vous parlez et les
mêmes j'allais dire prérogative qu'un
ordre professionnel je ne sais pas mais
mais je pense qu'il faille euh peut-être
l'avez-vous fait euh aller voir comment
comment ça fonctionne ailleurs je je
dois dire que je n'ai pas euh j'allais
dire je n'ai pas
de d'idée arrêté sur ce sujet et je
crois que vous non plus parce que vous
avez parlé d'hypothèse donc ça mérite
peut-être d'être regardé
oui ça pourrait être finalement 2
milliards donc c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est énorme la différence c'est
de 1 à 7 trait de l'au traitement de
l'eau ouis franis
interministériel qui a été publié il y a
15 jours et vous nous dites 2 milliards
donc là il y aura besoin d'une
clarification ma question elle portait
sur le coût santé publique effet phyau
est-ce que est-ce qu'on a des politiques
publiques sans mesures apparemment il y
a pas de mesur en la matière est-ce que
ça vous interroge alors les 2 milliards
j'ai dit c'est avec l'addition don ce
qu'on a fait avec les collectivités là
vous parliez de la part de l'État c'est
dire quand on regarde avec ce que
mettent les collectivités
euh voilà donc là
je pense qu'on n pas on n pas de de de
chiffres
ouais ben je je en fait on a une petite
idée sur l'air parce qu'on on sait le
nombre de décès qui serait duû à la
pollution de l'air mais pas par les
spécicides mais sur la pollution de
l'air parce qu'on on sait le chiffrer
par les maladies induites quand on parle
de pollution de l'air ce sujet on l'a
travaillé dans le cadre des
afeux là je pense que la question et je
reviens à ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
dans mon propos liminaire la crè d'une
Phyt
pharmacovigilance nous permettrait de
pouvoir classer ces produits et Infiné
Infiné d'avoir un chiffrage je le redis
la volonté et la nécessité de créer
cette
phytopharmacovigilance nous permettrait
de classer j'allais dire les pathologies
dues au pesticides et donc et donc à un
moment donné de pouvoir chiffrer quel
est l'impact réel des pesticides sur la
et sur les maladies dont on parle merci
madame la ministre nous nous nous
concluons cette audition avec vous sur
cette notion de phytopharmac viigilance
qui est une notion complètement centrale
qui sera certainement relevée dans les
recommandations à l'issue des travaux de
cette commission merci de vous être
rendu disponible merci de de votre
implication